it was a labor government of course that
managed to get the Good Friday agreement
across the line how did you look back on
it
I think the Good Friday agreement is one
of the defining Achievements not just
the last Labor government but but of the
labor movement throughout history I
think it's something everyone in this
country should cherish and support and
want to see succeed and there are
clearly the problems that the power
sharing as you've just outlined not up
and running as it should be but I think
everyone in this confusion support any
initiative to get that back on track and
should take pride in in how that
agreement came together and just what
can be achieved through negotiation and
the political process
should it take a president from the
United States to come over to try to get
the power sharing assembly back up and
running
oh look yeah all of us I think would
want a situation where that runs
smoothly that is not what the history of
Northern Ireland has been and it's not
the Contemporary political situation and
the United States has been a you know a
part of this process it has uh as a
nation invested time political time and
effort in the process it has a role to
play and if any of our friends and
allies can assist in getting Northern
Ireland back into that power sharing
position I think we should welcome that
so I think the attention the focus from
President Biden today is not something
anyone should feel uncomfortable with or
not want to see happen we need to use
everything we can to make sure we can
continue the tremendous progress
Northern Ireland has made and anyone who
is a good faith actor and partner in
that process should be welcomed
obviously trade will be something that
they'll take an opportunity
um to talk about I'm staying on your
brief I wonder if I could ask you about
the IMF predicting that the economy
would shrink by 0.6 it's now uh 0.3
contraction looks like um the chancellor
Jeremy Hunt is doing his job
couldn't give him that uh endorsement
Kate I mean it still shows the UK has
one of the worst performing major
economies in the world and I I find this
so frustrating I feel there's no reason
why we should be in this position I
think there are major major and exciting
opportunities this country could Embrace
and I I look good and use that example
for instance of President Biden look at
what he has done look how he is tried
and set forward this incredibly
comprehensive strategy to use Net Zero
as the basis for good jobs for good
sound unionized jobs you can build a
family around in every part of the
United States the level of ambition he
is showing is the kind of ambition I
want to see for the UK so that's what we
call our green Prosperity plan I think
that requires an industrial strategy to
make it work I think there are things we
can do to make the the trend cooperation
agreement to make brexit work more
smoothly I think there are things we can
do to devote power to different parts of
the country so we've got more economic
levers in each part of the country so
every bit of this country can succeed
and I I don't see anything on that scale
I'm afraid from the government and that
is what we want to do in that's why
we're so Keen to have that election and
put forward our prospectus to turn that
economic performance around your leaders
by the seaside today I believe is it
going to make him less nasty
this armor is is not a nasty Man by any
measure but he is the one who believes
it's fair to hold the government to
account I think after 13 years of
conservative government they've been in
power now the same length as the last
Labor government it is reasonable to do
so and whether we look at crime whether
we look at the NHS whether we look at
the performance of the economy I think
many conservative MPS are privately
pretty embarrassed by their record after
13 years and it's our job to hold them
to account but what he's also doing
today here is putting forward our plan
for the High Street putting forward a
five-point plan that would make a real
difference We Believe yes there's
internet shopping there's supermarkets
they play a major role but Town centers
still have a big role to play he's going
to talk about cutting business rates for
small business he's going to talk about
giving them help with the energy
transition tackling crime and
anti-social behavior in town centers
letting councils take over you know
shops that have been left boarded up so
you can bring them back into life these
are the positive things we're putting
forward but we're not going to shy away
from holding the government to account
okay because we think it is fair and
reasonable to do that as well at the
same time it's putting forward our more
positive offer
game
so I missed that question okay our wives
a fair game when it comes to attack
politics
and this is not about attacking
anybody's family but I think you're
making a reference to the non-dong
regime which is the the regime available
to the super rich a different tax regime
they can buy into we've been absolutely
clear we do not agree with this we
believe there is compelling research
that's been published by the London
School of Economics amongst others it
shows when changes were made to this
regime in the past it didn't produce
some sort of Exodus of high net worth
individuals who make a bigger
contribution in terms of the taxes they
pay we want to use that revenue from
ending that rule to expand the NHS
Workforce something which I think is
essential to fixing the problems in the
NHS but also frankly to address the the
workload or the NHS Workforce which is
clearly extreme and a significant cause
of their dissatisfaction and further
people leaving the NHS Workforce and we
think that is a compelling choice to
make so we're putting that forward and
it's not about attacking the Prime
Minister personally in any way but we
think there is a legitimate thing to put
forward as the kind of choice that we
would make which would be a much better
one for the country overall yeah but if
you're not attacking him personally why
use a photograph of him I so suppose
some might say but we've not got time to
explore that we will next time you come
in just before you go you talked about
the non-dom tax there would that solve
resolve the doctor present doctor strike
it will go some way to doing so I
wouldn't say in itself it will will do
everything that is required to bring
this dispute to an end but clearly I
think what we are seeing from people who
work at all levels in the NHS are
reasonable concerns about the workload
they're under the burden of that what
the pandemic has meant but actually the
situation they were in before we went
into that pandemic and I think any
long-term solution for the AHS and also
by the way to tackle the large numbers
of people who can't get back to work at
the minute in this country because
they're waiting for NHS treatment is to
recognize that there's got to be a way
to expand the number of doctors nurses
midwives community health workers our
plan for that is to end that non-dom
rule for the super rich over three
billion pounds of Revenue that we could
use to do that the chancellor himself
actually backed up when he was chair of
a select committee a little bit more
reticent to do so now but recognizing
the burden on NHS staff in the workforce
I think is integral to resolving issues
of industrial action in the NHS